something tell what did you think of
that episode good sir you can't fly I'm
sorry I think after seeing that last
dialogue at the end drove me a little
batty again a senile old person would
you want the tart toter at your house
ever yeah if he kept talking like that
at the end I'd be like holy smokes who
is this guy bring me into your world you
would film him and put him on line
wouldn't how do you know this whole
entire adventure time thing is not just
a part of like his mental breakdown yeah
everyone's like oh it's Finn's mental
breakdown I think it's that weird cookie
guys like that's all he see like you see
him floating backwards and it's like oh
he's just crazy in his own where a world
maybe it's a world within a world like
Inception Adventure ception this is the
other tarts and this is about Finn has
to take all these tarts to this castle
for the was it the back-rubbing ceremony
suddenly there's the greys tasting tarts
in the world and don't do that and he
has to get him there and apparently
princess Bubblegum's head is on the line
they're going to decapitate her and she
says it's so cheerfully and Finn thinks
up this brilliant plan apparently to go
through like the most dangerous route
that he can because I was the lodge
again like the thieves won't think you'd
be going that route they would follow
the actual tart toting path and they
wouldn't be waiting in these bad areas
for the tarts because that's where they
don't go so the same person would go
there so they'd have cinnamon bun go as
a decoy and it's just weird thing he's a
recurring character that was really
funny he was still saying bye and number
he's half-baked yes that is true
um that's a good joke - I remember that
that was a good joke and okay so he's
going there and he fin keeps making the
dumbest choices by going to the most
dangerous areas thinking they won't be
inhabited by dangerous people
and he gets there and he doesn't have
the tarts but cinnamon-bun got it there
in time and bubblegum says how I wasn't
got my head cut off it just in what you
eating a the tars which is like really
messed up and then this gingerbread
cookie guy comes in who used to carry
the tarts but he went nuts and old and
old and has heard the strange almost
Shakespearean sonnet to himself
high-fiving you yeah ending about
high-fiving you tomorrow which was
yesterday
something like that um very bizarre
what are these bubbling chemicals all
those are paralyzing yeah chemicals and
sterilized you forever I love I love how
the they were actually switched I love
how the paralyzing cards were it like so
all the feeds and people got the
paralyzing well that image of that
butterfly just totally paralyzed fly
look at this guy up I was gracious and
the voice of that butterfly was great -
it's only like a little bit but just
love the way talks just gonna go over
here but um and yeah the only thing I
found I was about to say the only thing
I found strange but wouldn't even be
remotely true oh because there's a lot
weird a strange stuff in this one but
the only one I found out of character
perhaps is that Finn would scrub as much
as he does like he really screws up in
this one like over and over it seems
more like something that like I don't
know like the Ice King would make the
serve mess up for Jake wood hey yeah
even Jake yeah because it's like Finn
usually is kind of on top of this stuff
and this is my you know it's like it's
like you got Bugs Bunny and Daffy Duck
like this it's like if Bugs Bunny was
doing this it's early well that seems
kind of a character like Daffy would do
that so it's I mean it's not entirely
bad cuz it's like you sometimes want to
see a character to you know get
something wrong you know or do something
would normally do you know add a little
bit more depth to him but at the same
time it's like it just seems so out of
character for him up
but not like I mean not something I was
like hey that destroyed the character or
anything like that but it was strange it
wasn't a LOD well I think it's been kind
of almost a slow build-up to it cuz
everyone smile you have Finn making a
mistake or doing something wrong and he
always has these crazy bizarre plans
that somehow just kind of seemed to work
and this is one of those crazy bizarre
plans that just fail all the way around
yeah if they think it's like yeah he did
give Simon Bond the you know the tarts
to go there but aside from that like he
nothing he did furthered anything to go
right everything just just failed and
it's just my blind walk that it turned
out happily yeah I like that personally
I thought it what I thought it in a
sense did add depth to the character and
it was like no he's not a perfect
character he screws up just as bad as
everyone hmm and I like that
yeah he was Kimmel on his high horse too
like that this plan is just so brilliant
and so I guess maybe that's Parvez just
like he's so proud of his plan that he's
trying to like go to his head I guess
you know just getting too much pride as
it does so yeah and I actually did see
that as someone showed me a clip of that
gingerbread man talking at the end it's
like hey just watch this and I just went
okay and I saw it out of context I
thought maybe when I see what the
episode it'll make more sense did not it
made actually less sense so I know who
showed it to you to Jim he did yes not
Jayraj Jim broken I showed that a long
time ago and it's just like yeah this
doesn't connect with anything just watch
it and I was like okay so that's a cat
show Adventure Time is all right it's
like it kind of is but there is it's
like there is a story but then they'll
just throw in weird strangeness like
that that with with the lumpy Space
Princess floating in the air and
grabbing the donut as it flies away that
was one of my favorites so yeah I mean a
good episode
only if fixed ramp was a little strange
like interest how constantly is screwing
up but I'm
like I said I don't think it destroys
the character like oh my god that was
awful it just seemed long odd to me one
other thing I liked is when Princess
Bubblegum calls him on the communicator
he's like oh no the classroom shoves it
under his head something wrong also
anyway we gets the second message a
third so yeah I mean that I don't
have too much else for her what do you
guys I mean you pretty much got it it's
a bizarre one with Finn learning that
he's not awesome all the time and I like
Jake with his little umbrella yeah I
like how they never questioned how like
were you just sniffing my butt yeah okay
I just we just looking my arm no okay
it's like another third time they
finally think maybe they should light a
match well actually at what I if you
notice he goes Jake were you just
sniffing my butt now ya know like he's
done it before
yeah he did that was really very bizarre
it's like my little arm no you know it
would be a little fire if he said now
yeah but again that's more of a that's
Marvin Jake ISM so I just invented the
term Jake ISM you're welcome Internet
no watch like some Jerry's gonna be like
it let me show you this is the screen
capya when I went on the message board
like okay yeah you you own it copy ready
so people get offended very easy right
angry maybe I get offended varying
easily angrily I I'm so upset I came in
formed words correctly right yes but you
have tree trunks back I just let should
bring you back call me down I do go to
your happy place I'm in my happy
you're freaking it's okay